l'halloween est l'occasion de se mettre
dans la peau d'un autre une pratique
peut soulever son lot de questions on
parle d'appropriation avec le sociologue
mathieu wade
jean mathieu
d'ailleurs c'est quoi ces enjeux là qui
sont soulevées avec la fête de la rue de
pub plusieurs années oui c'est la
question de savoir est ce qu'on peut se
mettre dans la peau de n'importe qui la
question de l'appropriation culturelle
c'est la manière dont on a un peu
problématiser cet enjeu la has est de
savoir est-ce qu'on peut s'approprier
des costumes des coiffes des manières
date de fer qui appartiennent à une
culture autre que la nôtre est donc
halloween c'est le moment tout désigné
pour se poser cette question là quand
justement commises et on se met dans la
peau d'un autre
on a plusieurs costumes qu'on a
peut-être décelé dans les allées où on
va aller les explorer pour savoir si
c'est possible acceptable ou peut-être
qu'il faut se poser la question avant de
squash
bon on a ici une coiffe autochtone
générique ça j'ai l'impression que ça
passerait pas le test de l'appropriation
culturelle
pourquoi parce que c'est un objet qu'une
signification sacré dans la culture
autochtone et sans soin se poserait pas
nécessairement problème on peut être
athée puis se déguiser en pas points en
bonne soeur en religieuse
la question c'est que la culture
autochtone elle a été totalement
marginalisée tellement mise à l'écart en
fait on à tenter de l'éradiquer au
canada et soudainement quand un blanc
s'approprier un élément de cette culture
là alors que la culture autochtone à peu
près absente de notre espace public
ça pose un problème parce qu'on est en
train de contourner un peu le sens
originel qui ont permet pas aux
autochtones de s'exprimer eux mêmes sur
la place publique on prend un symbole
pour s'exprimer un peu à leur place puis
de les réduire finalement un peu un
stéréotype ou un cliché donc ça j'ai
l'impression que ça passe pas le test
d'entrée - par exemple il ya des films
qui vont mettre à l'honneur certains
personnages qui sont autochtones ou ou
pas mais qui sont de cultures qui ont
été opprimés dans le passé on parle par
exemple de moana est ce qu'une jeune
fille une enfant qui voudraient se
déguiser en moins à ce qu'on entend par
an on peut se questionner mais là c'est
une tout autre question parce que là on
a affaire à des personnages fictifs
donc à partir d'une généralement l
empire désigne donc c'est vraiment des
personnages publics puis on se pose la
question à qui est ce qu'ils
appartiennent même si ils représentent
des cultures qui sont peut-être pas la
nôtre c'est quand même des héros et des
héroïnes mais qui sont aussi
contextualiser alors contrairement à la
coiffe autochtone ici qui est
complètement hors contexte se déguiser
en pocahontas par exemple des gens on
met en scène un personnage qui est plus
complexe qui représente être pas
fidèlement l'histoire telle que s'est
déroulée mais au moins c'est plus
complexe et on incarne un personnage et
non pas juste un stéréotype de un groupe
tout entier
mais on a ici le le costume de sorcier
afin que le personnage maléfique féminin
par acteurs excellents et quand on y
pense bon c'est juste une image que
coller à des femmes qui étaient
historiquement célibataire et qui
maniait les herbes donc des guérisseurs
demain les femmes qui correspondaient
pas aux moules de ce que vous voulez
l'église catholique puis la société
patriarcale et donc on a démoniser ces
femmes là et aujourd'hui on s'approprie
tout à fait cette image là alors que
c'est des grands de primes et de
l'histoire derrière ce n'est pas juste
des femmes il y avait des hommes aussi
mais les gens qui qui rentrait pas dans
ce moule là ont été stigmatisées puis le
costume de sorcières comme on l'a
aujourd'hui c'est la continuation de ce
stigmate initial donc je sais pas si
c'est très sensible de ceux déguisés en
sorcières et qu'il adopte donc ici on a
là la french made donc sur une femme de
ménage si on appartient à la classe
moyenne qu'on a un salaire conséquent
est ce qu'on peut se déguiser ce que
c'est une forme de domination encore
mais la base est sûre la classe
économique ou non donc est ce qu'on
entend par groupe qui est dominant qui
est dominée ça c'était de la question
qui se pose comment vous voyez comment
vous percevez peut-être les prochaines
années parce qu'elle sait des ballots
sont de plus en plus médiatisé de par
les réseaux sociaux de par l'accès à
l'information
comment est ce que vous voyez ces
débats-là évolué au cours des 12 années
étant donné que ça demain on vraiment de
l'ordre de l'indignation populaire
racines on n'a pas encore légiféré en
termes d'appropriation culturel sa
demande vraiment quelque chose qui se
passe sur les réseaux sociaux puis on
essaye collectivement de trouver des
frontières puis je pense qu'au fur et à
mesure qu'on va essayer d'imposer de
plus en plus de français il va y avoir
des mouvements opposés ou est ce qu'on
essaye de pousser encore plus les
limites je pense pas qu'on va arriver à
un terrain d'entente
je pense qu'on va continuer à s'indigner
puis on va continuer à se repousser ses
frontières